hey it's my birthday and I've organized
a birthday made up with 20 of my
followers so we're just about to head to
the location right now there's lots to
set up lobster prep and I'll be serving
healthy yummy food drinks and I've also
created special gift boxes for each and
every one of my followers so I'm really
looking forward to this meetup because
I'll be meeting most of them for the
first time and I'm sure we will just be
chatting away it's going to be a really
relaxing evening and I'm really looking
forward to get to know each of them
better I'm here at signature at the roof
to celebrate my birthday party with all
my followers so let's head inside and
see what my team is up to
let's go there's so much to set up so
right now we're just busy prepping the
space and we're going for a pastel white
theme now we're putting together the
final touches
[Music]
the ladies are finally here is truly
amazing to be in a room filled with
like-minded women there's just so much
love and I feel extremely blessed
[Music]
it's my party and I got to make sure
that the food I'll be serving are
healthy and delicious for starters were
serving roasted beet root with
cauliflower tabouleh and also Japanese
sweet potato salad and for the mains we
have chicken kabob skewers with millet
quinoa pulao and also whole wheat penne
spinach and Warner pesto
topped with grilled Norwegian salmon oh
my god sounds so delicious what's a
party without the drinks there are
several great cocktails you can make
with Dom B for my party I'll be serving
their signature cocktail and the
Singapore sling the dumb cocktail has a
sweet unique taste which I enjoy it is a
mix of dumby sparkling wine and a twist
of lemon it's a big deal for me okay
it's a big deal that you all took all
this effort to make your time to be here
this time around I thought you'll be fun
to do my birthday meet up because I
really want to get to know the people
that has been watching my videos all
these years so very lucky gathering what
is healthy but also very yummy we really
enjoy our time it was really chill eggs
we really enjoy yourself and yeah all
the girls out there they are really
having fun thank you sure don't be was
good
I enjoy the drink it's really fruity it
goes really well with fire with the food
well open the gift volume wah it's like
of the best gift that will be wrong yeah
thank you so much you're allowed a
little gift I'll be back
I'm all the way from Philippines I
really really admire her she really
changed my soul my social life and also
my food habit
I actually saw some pictures of me it
was so bad it was really very bad I have
a 72 kg basically after two months I've
been working out I've been eating at
home I reduce my weight to 49 from 72 to
49 and happy birthday continue doing
what you do right make a wish
thank you so much for coming ladies
let's Cheers
it was an amazing evening made even more
special by having all of you with me
[Music]